Detroit Motor City the city that was
once a symbol of u.s. industrial might
now can't deal with its thousands of
thirsty residents who've been using the
hashtag Detroit water why are they
thirsty because as the cost of water in
this city has gone up by a hundred and
twenty percent in the last decade
thousands of Detroit residents are
behind on their water bills so what did
the bankrupt city decide to do shut off
water to thousands of Detroit's poorest
households every week because that's the
humane thing to do the Detroit water
department actually tweeted if you're
stealing water we're coming after you
yes that was an official tweet and yes
people are pissed
twitter user sugary said how can we be a
first world country let alone
exceptional while denying clean water
but guess what it gets worse why
low-income communities are going without
water
a Detroit golf course football stadium
and hockey arena Oh millions in unpaid
water bills but so far their faucets are
still running holiday d'un tweeted that
44% of Detroiters are below the poverty
line and 14,000 households are without
water memes have blasted how ridiculous
the situation is given that Detroit is
surrounded by a whole lot of fresh water
you know the Great Lakes another meme
was quick to condemn the USS misplaced
priorities but just because the
government isn't helping doesn't mean
fellow citizens are not Detroit water
brigade a volunteer alliance of Detroit
residents is working to bring emergency
relief to families cut off from water
and the largest union of nurses in the
u.s. is organizing a protest July 18th
to demand action they've called the
whole situation a public health
emergency meanwhile an American should
take note even the United Nations has
timed in the UN office of the High
Commissioner for Human Rights which
usually focuses on places like Myanmar
in Afghanistan warned Detroit it could
be violating the human right to water
which you're guaranteed even if you
can't pay for it the Detroit water
department told a day plus there are
assistance programs for people
struggling with their water bills but do
you think this sort of cruel austerity
is needed to get Detroit back on track
if not use the hashtag Detroit water to
show solve the
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook